[Music]
welcome back river babes I'm Liana
gelareh and I may be embracing my inner
weirdo and rocking this awesome Jughead
beanie but this week's preview episode
of Sweetwater secrets is all about Betty
and Veronica please enlighten me now you
guys it was a gut-wrenching moment when
the black hood forced Betty to turn on
Veronica I don't like sharing and as we
move into episode 206 chapter 19 death
Proof DMVs friendship is still on the
rocky side you better shut it down Betty
or what Veronica luckily for all you out
there I have got the inside scoop
straight from Camilla Mendez and Lily
Reinhardt all about Betty Ann Veronica's
BFF breakup and the behind-the-scenes
secrets of how cami and Lily's real-life
friendship first began but first I just
want to say thank you all so much for
the flood of fantastic comments on last
week's episode of sweet on our secrets
here are a couple of my faves okay
so Megan James said I love sweet water
secrets on Wednesdays and Thursdays I
look forward to it all week thank you so
much for watching Megan Isabelle maze
wrote honestly so obsessed with the show
madellaine you are such a great actress
and Leanne worked that vixen shirt thank
you I tried and Emma McGuire commented
anyone else think it's turning into PLL
not in a bad way but you know the black
hoodie
Cheryl is basically Mona everyone loves
and hates her at the same time and the
fact that LeAnn is doing the show
haha it's happening again and we're
gonna do something about it what can I
say Emma I'm addicted to covering teen
murder mystery dramas that have awesome
characters ridiculously attractive stars
and amazing fandoms moving on
alright guys episode 205 was the biggest
episode of the season and so much went
down with the arrival of mega douche
Nick st. Clair I'd be thinking of ways
you might start showing me some
appreciation but right now I want to
take the time to focus on the fact that
Betty and Veronica aka the most iconic
duo on TV right now
yeah I said it you guys they gotten
their first vicious fight excuse me
now of course we know that Betty didn't
really mean to give Veronica's verbal
whiplash because it was really the black
hood pulling the puppet strings but
Ronnie certainly didn't know that so
here's what Lily and cami had to tell me
about filming the fight I love of course
Betty and Veronica and their friendship
but of course all friendships go through
their ups and downs I know that they're
gonna be having things test it a little
bit what can you tease about that
dynamic I think in season 1 obviously
they've kind of started off on the wrong
foot you know they don't really have
problems necessarily as friends but in
season 2 as any female friendship or as
any friendship in general you're gonna
have some issues in episode 5 we get to
play kind of a fight it's inevitable and
it happens with every person in your
life and so you know it's bound to
happen which mean Betty and Bronco in it
and it does but it's coming from a good
place
Betty's in a situation where she needs
to sacrifice her friendship with
Veronica in order to protect her I can't
exactly explain the circumstances but it
is really sad and and hard to see these
two girls fight Veronica's obviously
hurt but they do eventually today when
they make up you're happy rooting for
them again you don't want to see people
fight you wanna see two people who are
like such a good duo fight yeah and be
on bad terms with one another but I feel
like it does add that layer of realism
to the relationship and and its
strengths that strengthens their bond
have a least it's not about a boy yes
which I'm very glad about yes which we
are - oh I agree thank goodness it's not
about a boy but I was still pretty
pissed to watch it all go down and a lot
of you guys were too you know you guys
left nearly 700 comments on the last
aftershow episode of sweet water secrets
and almost all of them were your kisses
and kisses I loved reading them all and
here were a few of my faves okay so
Shelly Brady wrote what an episode that
was hisses - Nick bug head split
had getting punched by the Serpent's
Tony and Jughead kiss I couldn't watch
and her kisses were to the Pussycats
kicking Knicks but yeah Alice Cooper
showing up at the party shove it Hal and
hot dog finally being introduced and she
sent big kisses to sweep utter secrets
writing I'm addicted can we please get
more episodes I hate waiting a week for
the next episode of Riverdale that's
very nice of you we're already giving
you two episodes a week so I hope you're
enjoying them because I love making them
for you
Cassidy Jackson commented I think that
bug head will come back later but I'm
not happy that jug already kissed Tony
the same day but he broke up with him
like kill your boss Jim
I agree girl Sadie said oMG major hits
Tony and black hood I can't believe Tony
kissed jug and just OMG and the black
hood telling Betty girl get rid of these
people and especially Jughead like OMG
and I can't believe what Archie said and
what he said the jug and I cried the
whole hour and I do not ship Jughead and
Tony and I'm upset lull Haiti that was
quite the emotional journey that you
went on I'm so glad you took us along
for the ride
on the flipside just an ordinary fangirl
said am I the only one who shifts Tony
and Jughead more than Betty and Jughead
I'm sure you're not the only person on
that ship but it's probably a smaller
boat but hey you do you girl and my
favorite new ship alert is courtesy of
the psycho Chronicles who wrote I ship
hotdogs and Jughead their ship name is
hothead and it is now a religion in that
case I am sending my prayers Russ to the
TV gods
alright guys seriously I love reading
all of your comments especially your
hisses and kisses so please keep them
coming huh alright now things have been
beyond stressful in Riverdale lately so
I wanted to give you guys an exclusive
present from me to you to make you smile
take a look at this adorable moment with
cami and Lily in a new segment called
first impressions
[Music]
the et audience loves your friendship
with Tammy tell me about your first
impression of campaign where you were
when you met her
Tammy and I met at the network test for
the show and I remember she was running
like this little green turtleneck like
sleek straight hair very put together
like very gorgeous girl and I was like
okay well she was so quiet like she
barely talked to anybody she was like
very in the zone very reserved but I was
like that girl is gonna be Betty like as
soon as I met her I'm like that study
and Cole was in the room he was sitting
across the table and kind of had his
back turned to us a little bit and it
was like inquisitive and like going over
his eyes I think and really talked to
him much because he seemed to be in his
own little world I never really talked
to any of them she just seemed like the
perfect person for the role maybe we
like went to the bathroom together and
we're talking about how nervous we were
and then I got to know her I was like
wow we're really different but our
differences kind of made us get along
even more once we booked the role once
we got together she reminded me and does
or any of my best friends that I have
that I grew up with in Ohio and you know
so we get along really well we're just
both really really goofy and it's fun to
have that what's your go-to like girls
night activity probably like staying and
ordering the pizza watching movies like
we're trying to plan this night we've
had no time but we're trying to plan
this night where we watched Lizzie
McGuire movie together
hash tag friendship gold now if you guys
were BFFs with lily and cami what was
your ideal girls night be head on down
to the comments and tell me and while
you're there shout out your thoughts on
what you'd like to see on future
episodes of sweet butter secrets all
right guys now be sure to check back
with me after you watch episode 206
chapter 19 death Proof to freak out with
me over all the high-speed drama and
please give this video a like subscribe
to EJ's YouTube channel and remember to
ring the bell so you never miss an
episode of Sweetwater secrets stay weird
river babes
[Music]
you